and we were having a conversation yeah
you know but we're not making we're not
making declarations yeah sure the fact
that having a conversation is dangerous
is so telling that people need to be
having these conversations that's why
that's why we Pilar here with us right
now because they want to have this
conversation people want this they want
to show that that's why people get so
mad at black lives matter that the
phrase but of course it does of course
your lives matter no they're trying to
convince the the general public that
there's people out there that don't feel
that way when people when people respond
with no well all lives matter they're
saying no one believes that because we
believe all lives are do matter the idea
is that all lives matter encompasses
black lives matter right there is there
is an issue I take with it in that
people respond with all lives matter
right if someone yells black lives
matter I'd say hear hear yes yes exactly
I completely agree yeah stop you all
right right stop trying to prove them
wrong cuz black lives do matter yes
you're right you're absolutely right
they absolutely matter no doubt no
question this is the way I put it like
the big problem right now is the
far-left manipulating and so you end up
with these people who are saying things
like black lives matter but then using
that as a Trojan horse to bring in
communism mm-hmm another weird
socialists down with the patriarchy is
one of the section one is the top lists
on the black lives matter movement way
apart in the family why that breaking
apart the family what yep it's the great
equalizer that's that's ridiculous
there's a creepy commercial there's a
direct correlation with with not having
a father figure and a mother figure and
it's a crime he's going up
oh just excuse me okay to parents we
need more research on it sure I was
actually reading because this is a big
conversation having to do with LGBT
rights okay and the I can't remember
exactly which one it is but was one of
the intellectual dark web high-profile
anti so anti intersectional as people
who said the current data we have shows
that you need two parents a single
parent household is what results in you
know like higher crime rates in stuff
like this yeah fatherlessness
does play a specific role
but they ultimately said we need to do
more research on whether or not it's
specifically male/female or just two
parents but so far the day we have is
two parents okay I'm not kind of being
to be you know the scientist who has all
the answers well and I'm certainly not
you know I I just every day I further
myself a little more than the day before
and I really try to understand more and
more and especially now I'm seeing that
that you know the the classic nuclear
family that like people talk about it's
like that that's needed we need that we
need to cherish that because that that
breeds more community you know people
are they grow up with with a I don't
know a sense of of worth they've
actually can see who how to be you know
and that's what they strive to be it's
hard it's hard to know to be honest you
know when I look at the data pertaining
to families it's hard to know for sure
yeah but that question is why is
breaking apart there's a traditional
family structure of goal of how that
lives matter why it makes no sense it
doesn't it doesn't make any sense at all
it doesn't make any sense the Trojan
horse they found the way in yep
absolutely
so here's the way I see it you know my
response and I think the appropriate
response if someone I was talking to a
friend of mine we were arguing about a
lot of politics okay and I was asked
will you know so actually Eric's well
well he's the guy who farted on MSNBC
yeah cheap an election he said in in in
Congress is there any Republican who can
unequivocally say black lives matter and
then no one speaks up and I think was
Matt gates who says he said something
like yes they do and all lives matter or
something like that
and he's like no just say black lives
matter my response is absolutely you
know if someone came to me and said so I
was talking to my friend and they said
would you agree that black lives matters
have 100 percent absolutely I will hold
that sign right along with you yeah and
I would also then say to the people with
all lives matter signs I'd shake their
hand to and say hey you know how about
you you know you guys who are concerned
about you know Tony temple I think his
name was right yeah I feel your pain
your you're completely right the people
mad about brennentaylor you are also
right hey guess what you're both right
yeah what if we work together
boom justice for all of these people and
then it doesn't need to be about your
slogan separating us based on tribe we
can actually come together yeah and you
know what maybe maybe we say I
this if you think the Branagh tailor is
or or George Floyd is more deserving of
attention than say Tony Tempah I'm not
gonna argue I'm gonna say alright I will
fight with you for justice for George
Floyd under I would do it
unconditionally to be honest but I ask
you a favor
afterwards can we talk about Tony tempo
yeah and guess what people are gonna say
yeah of course
yep so you know I the way I see it is
there's there is real compromise between
say actual black lives matter activists
not the Trojan horse for leftists who
have hijacked the movement yeah yes
which is what many of the high-profile
black lives matter people have said if
someone comes to me and says police
brutality is affecting my community I'm
like let me know what you need me to do
man well let me know because I'm not
down with people having their civil
rights violated agreed right that
includes tearing down a community statue
because it's violating the rights of
people who live there mm-hmm that
includes someone losing their life to at
the hands of cops and the cops not be
held accountable yeah so you end up with
these you know conflicting slogans that
don't need to be conflicting at all yep
you know it's like can you hope a sign
with both you have a sign saying black
lives matter and all lives matter and
let's like work together to fight for
those who have lost their lives on
justly boom there's a foot there's like
there's a bunch of memes that go around
about this that for some reason seek to
discredit all I've mattered and I'm not
good though me neither it's like both
sides arguing over the sky is blue it's
blue
no it's it's a darker shade of blue it's
like no LULAC it's blue everyone black
it's Hollow
you're talking about refracting
particles that's an illusion no I don't
care about that I'm telling you I can
see it it's blue instead of being like
friends friends you're both just so
awful regular people understand that
literally the sky is black and that due
to reflecting more you know water
molecule particle apartment molecules or
whatever it creates an illusion it is
actually cool to think about the fact
that the blue light you see is just one
part of the spectrum of colors that is
shining through it's just sunlight yeah
refracted it's pretty cool I think this
picture I found it in two seconds I'm so
good at what I do not that one this one
there we go
oh yeah yeah this is great so this is a
very famous image
then I see all the time I don't know
what what it's origin is but look at the
camera for that for those that it wasn't
only explain it to you there is a man
with a knife chasing a man on camera it
looks like the man running is actually
the man doing the stabbing because the
camera only captures a specific portion
of you know the incident so it's a
really interesting way of thinking about
how media narratives frame what's
actually going on yeah uh nails it
basically the guy running his his foot
is pointed and the guy swinging the
knife is screaming so on camera you see
a guy screaming and a pointed object
coming his way but in reality the guy
screaming is the one doing the stabbing
so it's it's a it's a good
representation of how the media skews
our perspective of everything but going
you know I want to go back to you know
you're talking about your arguments with
people on Facebook you go why are people
arguing with you on Facebook because
because I'm being vocal and I'm asking
questions that's that's really the thing
I'm asking questions
you know it honestly it all started from
someone posting a meme it was you know
the it's you know black lives matter say
put we need police reform and then
they're like okay let's get rid of
Antrim I'm on and they're like yeah okay
well what about police reform and they
get rid of Uncle Ben's and then yeah but
what about police reform and there was a
bunch of different things and then
someone started writing it's like the
Republicans tried to do this and blah
blah well I mean I'm like not not the
specific not specifically like what is
going on in their minds where they're
like aha Adams had something I must be
angry with him well that's that's what
we're seeing we're seeing people that
are swayed by the mainstream media
they're they're they're running on
emotions so so they they get triggered
whenever they see someone that doesn't
that isn't speaking to the narrative
that they they want what do they get
that's a great question I don't know I
there's I'm starting to figure that out
myself so when we break this down what
do we have we have Republicans offered
up a reform policy you know Democrats
shot it down yep so if so what are these
people arguing for if they're not
winning anything I don't I don't know
and they're not they're not only are
they not winning anything they're mad at
the Republicans in this situation
because I all I said was the
the person who posted the meme and then
someone responded and I just said hey
look I I because of my job I'm I'm
actually really aware of things that are
going on in the political realm and this
is actually true the the Republicans put
forward with a bill and the Democrats
shut it down and period so what I said
was just the truth right
nothing nothing more no biased but man
did I get blasted people were just oh
haha nice try nice try and then they you
know posting these pomp anti-trump memes
and like saying all this stuff about how
they got me and I'm just like what do
you mean like I literally just said the
truth this is this actually happened
they did shut it down and they're like
yeah well you're you're clearly biased
because you said the Dems shut it down
so you're clearly not a Democrat you
hate Democrats and I'm just like you you
guys are changing
no no not changing they're adding their
own narrative and and I guess their
nuance to what I said and making it fit
they're what they want to scream about
we need sports back we need we need we
need sports actually know that that's
funny that you should say that I agree I
agree sports are a way for us to blow
off steam we can we haiti from you can
hate each other
comfortably or you like that team well i
like this team bra and it answers that
and we haven't really realized that
video games are the new sport that it is
that new the newer version of it you
know people you get that you know it's
eSports I don't it's huge that's why
it's so big because everyone has access
to it but it's you don't have to be
physically fit you don't have to be good
at sports all you need is good hand-eye
coordination so look when I when I was
younger I used to actually get mad that
people were so obsessed with sports
because they'd argue about Sox versus
Cubs and it was always partial like
typically you know a little bit in jest
yeah but I mean it's not even an
argument Cubs are better sure actually
not actually clearly a couple mystically
they're not no they're not statistically
alright this
socks have been a better team but the
Cubs finally just won and I've been to
many Cubs games you know I sang with
Harry Caray I you know I've been to
regular field I got a I got a big soft
spot for Chicago sports teams I think I
think all in all sports have been kind
of dwindling and you know it doesn't say
when I was younger I was actually mad
that people wouldn't pay attention of
the world around them because they were
too obsessed with sports now as I get
older I'm like maybe that's a good thing
because people don't actually care it's
gonna fight you that's why I was asking
you like why are they arguing with you
because that's a good point
listen I read the news literally all day
every single day yeah I just read news
and it's funny when you get these far
left as being like Tim's no to real
journalists all he does is read articles
it's like bro
do you know like how much research have
to do every single day you claim that
you only work for or I record right but
for about three and a half four hours to
four hours of content right and that you
twelve out all day long I trust me I see
it all day long this guy is a machine he
is just constantly research researching
backchat all day long doubling down yeah
it's it's amazing tell you what they're
they're several instances were like
you'll bring something up like hey I
heard this and I'll say oh actually
that's not true because of this debt
unless you're like really Wow and then
we'll look it up then sometimes you're
like oh actually I found the source it's
true no but oh wow how about that you
know and then several instances I'm like
actually here's the source of that meme
and so when it comes to like that story
about the dude driving the car on the
highway I watched like five different
videos you know I watched the live chimp
from the one who got hit as she was
Jimmy as she got hit oh wow I read all
the articles and I said here's what's
actually happened and then you have all
these people who are like on team left
who aren't reading it saying he drove
around the police barricade and then
went the wrong way on the highway and
hit somebody and I'm like and that's the
truth didn't happen so I'm gonna sorry
MIT to everyone so here's what I see
happening you have people on Facebook
who argue with me and it's the funniest
thing so I'm like with with all due
respect what do you do for a living and
they'll say like what is the answer
someone will tell me like Oh IIIi I'm a
warehouse forklift operator I say okay
okay let me let me let me just make this
point okay and again with all due
respect I respect your opinion however
and it's
certain point wouldn't you defer to the
experts on the issue yeah and so I
actually got an argument this dude and
he was talking about how much smarter he
was and how he knew all these things and
I say you realize that I have like been
doing this for a decade I read nothing
but news all day every day non-stop from
all different sources fact-checking all
day every day ten years ten years okay
would you go to a doctor when he says
here's my prescribed treatment and go I
read actually on Twitter that this says
I shouldn't be doing you know what you
prescribe and that's why I got really
mad when Trump was talking about
hydroxychloroquine treatment for covet
and then all these pundits were like
don't do it it's gonna get dangerous
like Cavuto on Fox News was like it'll
kill you I don't look done another stop
don't say that news people listen your
doctor please write all this in a trump
listen your doctor if your doctor says
it safe trust your doctor that's all I
can really say and technically speaking
Trump I behaved I watched that speech he
was actually referring to a from a
doctor as doctor that that's told him
that so he was like this is something
that they're finding this is the and
it's promising and people like why would
someone want to argue so bad that they
would think they know better than I do
when I'm being respectful no I'm not
insulting them I'm just saying here's
the source I can prove what I'm saying
and and their sources Amin and so I
actually told this guy I was like bro
look I'm done playing games you're as
far as I can tell like you to me are
like an auntie back sir
yeah like you've got a doctor saying
here's what I think about the medication
and then you're just like nope don't
care I work in a warehouse but I know
better than you so that's why like for
me like on the issues of vaccines or
massacres I look man yeah I got to be
honest when it comes to foul Chi I don't
listen to a word that guy says anymore
same here you know and I'm not the only
one saying that there like a lot of
people have finally come out and been
like he clearly doesn't know what he's
talking about
yeah it's pretty obvious but but I still
defer to the doctor so here's what I say
listen ignore the public PR debate over
like masks and all that stuff and and
the prop and it is a problem when our
governors are playing PR politics you
know instead of actually what we need
ask your doctor if your doctor says wear
it I take your doctor's advice that's
all I can say yeah so the
problem with tribal politics instead of
tribal sports is that people now are
invested in simply fighting for the sake
of fighting because they have a they
have their team you know well it's in
our nature I'm on if you wanna fight
left you're on team right therefore I'm
gonna fight you and it's like this is
actually negatively impacting our way of
life can you go back to talking about
Sox versus Cubs again cuz at least then
you deferred politics that people who
are more interested it's I don't even
think it's that people want to fight I'm
gonna correct myself that I just said
that because when I look at it it's it's
people want a purpose and as little of a
purpose it is to just be rooting for a
sports team that that fills that purpose
I'm so proud that my team won and I've
got my friends that love my team we you
you got community right you've got a
purpose you've got something you're
looking forward to you're excited about
the game on the weekend you're looking
forward to it doesn't matter what you do
I've already got a rivalry you got
someone to like hate upon and like in
the best way possible what you got some
bad yeah so I think people mostly just
want to be long and I think that's what
being part of a fan group is boom I
think that's why I support so important
because I have it long said I don't
really care for sports I don't fall
sports and I was like Tim I thought that
people who followed sports were kind of
silly mm-hmm but I was like if it gives
them something to like rally around and
someone cheer for you know an enemy
that's not harmful to root against oh
where is the harm here as long as you're
also focusing online and seriously if
for all the people that are on Team Tim
cast IRL why haven't you smashed the
like button yeah great that's what
that's what I'm saying that's what I'm
talking about
why aren't you smashed in the like
button we should have 50,000 likes right
now we smash it hold on I'm not done I'm
gonna smash the like button yeah all
right I'm good you can continue now you
know typically when I learned that when
I read the history about like the
Coliseum uh-huh you know breads bread
and circuses you know usually negative
like the people were distracted from the
real issues that oppressed them in
exchange for being thrown loaves of
bread right or actually I love I love
the we splashed water world have you
guys when was the last time you guys
watched Waterworld of Kevin Costner the
smokers sinneth so-and-so thing
the guy is like driving through the ship
and he's throwing cigarettes to
everybody that's that's kind of it like
we look back on this rather negatively
yeah but maybe humans need something to
make them to be a part of something yeah
otherwise there'll be a part over there
something more violent that's true or
they'll they'll shield violence so if
the team sport right now I think this is
it I think Democrats in their
desperation tried to weaponize tribal as
tribalist politics and that's like the
one ring they couldn't they couldn't do
it properly yeah and they've unleashed
the demons that they should not have
unleashed when they lost a trump they
didn't know why and so even even during
the campaign against Trump they were
trying to embrace this escalating
progressive far-left
they didn't you know I think I think
Bernie actually caused a lot of problems
for them line cited them I could see
that it's very obvious to me that when
you look at how they were handling the
Democratic primary it was gonna be a
very quick drop out to make sure Hillary
won yeah because she was supposed to win
a no 8 and Obama stole it that's true so
then I think their plan was it was gonna
be her but Bernie had a real grassroots
moment they could not contain it's true
and so their only option to try it
themselves well Walter was to pander to
Bernie's base right saying how do you
how do you stop the rebellion in the
ranks the Democratic Party because you
know what the real problem was everybody
hates Hillary Clinton I'm not
exaggerating everyone the the the the
the few people who pretend to like her
are just scared of her there are cronies
who are in the game who are happy with
her yeah but I probably she wanted the
presidency and I think I blame her 100%
for the demise of the modern Democratic
Party as it stands today yeah because
she it was her turn she had to be
president even if it means destroying
everything so what happened because she
was so hated by people a large portion
of the Democratic voter base at Bernie
Sanders and then the Democrats went to
panic mode trying to stop the rebellion
within their ranks and the only way to
do it was to shut burning up but then
pander to his base otherwise the revolt
would continue you know and they
couldn't stop it
if Hillary in my opinion it wasn't
Hillary I don't know who they would have
run if you had someone who is more
charismatic there would not be a far
left insurgency among the Democratic
Party for the most part okay because a
charismatic leader like you know Obama
was for universal health care in his
first term I didn't know that he never
got it done okay he said by the end of
my mark my word by the end my first term
we will have universal health care or
something like that never happened and
that's a pretty far left position but he
was still widely popular I'm on the
Democratic Party even after his second
term ended they could have found someone
who was like Obama and I'm not saying
about most good he's a horrifying things
especially in terms of war if they had
found somebody who is just charismatic
there wouldn't have been the Bernie
uprising in my opinion yeah now they're
probably still would have been a big
populist insurgency because that
happened on the right and the left with
Bernie and Trump Trump probably still
would have won but the Democrats today
would be fit would be fighting a very
different fight they would have in my
opinion a real chance to defeat Trump
cuz what I've always said is Trump is
moderate on a lot of policy but and he's
done great by the economy he started no
new Wars he wants to bring our troops
back he has really hidden a lot of these
key important points that the regular
Americans care about nuke if the
Democrats had someone who had those
exact same policies but was clean
mouthed Hussein does put it lightly yeah
I think they'd win you know I easily
you'd like his you I think they'd really
really win Trump does look when you win
you listen to what Trump has to say you
realize he's not nearly as bad as the
media makes him out to be huh but Trump
does behave in a way that's very easy to
weaponize against him unfortunately for
him they use it and there was there was
a viral post on Reddit where Trump was
doing the thing with his arm
I don't you ever see this yeah and
someone commented I don't know how this
wasn't the end of Trump as soon as it
came out and then people mentioned the
the locker room talk tapes and stuff
like that and the reality was those
people who are like how did that not end
Trump never looked into what what what
it was exactly and the people who did
their news from memes they get their
news from memes and I read it and on
Facebook and unfortunately for the
Democrats lobbies people are gonna vote
you know like the young people who get
their news from memes it's not gonna
happen thanks for checking out this clip
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show live
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if you
want to catch the full show tune in to
this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you